even though we're only a few months into
the new decade the 2020s have already
been defined by an international health
crisis known as kovat 19 after
originating in the Wuhan province of
China this particularly dangerous form
of coronavirus has spread throughout the
world at a much faster rate than most
could have anticipated creating a
worldwide atmosphere of fear as a virus
deadlier than the seasonal flu strikes
the most vulnerable populations to try
and prevent the incredibly rapid spread
of kovat 19 some countries are limiting
travel and closing their borders after a
terrible outbreak Italy placed limits on
all travel and put its residence under a
strict quarantine essentially closing
some of the world's most historically
relevant major cities and unsurprisingly
this shutdown has also affected the
entertainment industry in a big way film
festivals and premiers are getting
rescheduled and canceled right and left
in between quarantine shooting locations
contaminated cast and crew members and
concerns about crowds attending new
movies a lot of projects have ground to
a screeching halt in the face of kovat
19 one of the first cinematic casualties
of kovat 19 was the final outing for
Daniel Craig as James Bond Bolton one of
the biggest movies of the spring season
in early March of 2020 MGM Universal and
the producers of no time to die announce
that the film's original release date of
April 10th 2020 would no longer come to
fruition and the film would instead have
to wait until November 25th 2020 here
late in a statement obtained by the BBC
the producers explain their reasoning
saying just one person who may not even
show symptoms can infect the rest of the
audience it's just a movie the health
and well-being of fans around the world
and their families is more important we
have all waited for over four years for
the spell another few months will not
damage the quality of the film and only
help the box-office for Daniel Craig's
final hurrah though Saban fans will
definitely be disappointed by this delay
it's clear that the reasoning behind the
choice wasn't just sound but
extraordinarily considerate to those
most affected by this virus certainly
Craig and crew wanted fans to see their
newest film as soon as possible but this
humane and prescient decision will
absolutely protect people from this
viral outbreak as well as drum up even
more anticipation for Craig's final Bond
film as Kovan 19 spreads the atmosphere
surrounding this pandemic is becoming
more tense and frightening and as such a
stark dystopian tale about an alien
apocalypse might not be a huge
theatrical success
right at this exact moment that might be
just one reason as to why a quiet place
part 2 the sequel to John Krasinski's
directorial for debut which premiered to
rave reviews in 2018 has been officially
placed on the back burner for the spring
release season in a statement paramount
announced that though they were placed
in a quiet place part two on a temporary
hold they don't yet have a new release
date for the film which finds emily
Blunt's character trying to protect her
family and a world where monsters can
track your every sound producers from
the movie said in the statement after
much consideration and in light of the
ongoing and developing situation
concerning coronavirus and restrictions
on global travel and public gatherings
Paramount Pictures will be moving the
worldwide release of a quiet place part
two we believe in and support the
theatrical experience and we look
forward to bringing this film to
audiences this year once we have a
better understanding of the impact of
this pandemic on the global theatrical
marketplace the CW's while this teen
show is also facing delays as a result
of kovat 19 leaving the residents of
Riverdale in the lurch the Archie Comics
adaptation which also faced a series of
hardships in 2019 due to the unexpected
death of series star Luke Perry was
forced to halt production as a result of
possible contamination The Hollywood
Reporter announced that the Vancouver
set production put a hold on shooting
its upcoming fourth season out of an
abundance of caution after someone on
the show's team may have come in contact
with the virus at the time of the
announcement the delay was open-ended
though Riverdale fans will undoubtedly
be disappointed the health of the cast
and crew is obviously the most important
consideration for the show if fans were
hoping that the next Fast and Furious
film would arrive on file a fast and
furious schedule it looks like they'll
be disappointed if this is a joke huh in
the wake of the Cova 19 outbreak Fast
and Furious 9 is facing a serious delay
moving its release date by a full year
to accommodate audiences trying to avoid
this virus Universal Studios announced
that the film would be delayed nearly a
full year jumping from May 22nd 2020 to
April 2nd 2021 as the team said on
Twitter we feel all the love and the
anticipation you have for the next
chapter in our saga that's why it's
especially tough to let you know that we
have to move the release date of the
film it's become clear that it won't be
possible for all of our fans around the
world to see the film this may though
the Fast & Furious crew knows there
fans are bummed they reassured their
loyal followers that the decision was
made with safety in mind while we know
there is disappointment and having to
wait a little while longer this move is
made with the safety of everyone as our
foremost consideration moving will allow
our global family to experience our new
chapter together
we'll see you next spring even the
Marvel Cinematic Universe isn't immune
to coronavirus concerns along with
several other Disney projects the
upcoming Disney Plus show the Falcon and
the Winter Soldier which follows Anthony
Mackie and Sebastian Stan as Sam Wilson
and Bucky Barnes has been delayed due to
this growing pandemic exactly what
effect this will have on the series is
intended Paul 2020 premiere remains to
be seen as one good strategy the
production was shut down while filming
in Prague in the heart to the Czech
Republic Stan took to Instagram to
address Marvel fans lavishing praise
upon Prague in the production itself
with the caption Prague what a city
we've been shooting the Falcon in the
Winter Soldier and experiencing one of
the most beautiful cities in the world
filled with the most wonderful and
welcoming people now we are being sent
home too soon frog you're gonna be in my
thoughts for a long time thank you we'll
be back thinking of you these two
superheroes might be unstoppable in the
MCU but kovat 19 is put their story and
cryofreeze for now in the midst of a
frightening pandemic audiences are
looking for escapist fare more than ever
but unfortunately some upcoming romantic
comedies are getting shelved until
further notice due to the virus one such
casualty is the lovebirds Paramount's
upcoming rom-com starring issa ray and
Kumail Nanjiani which has been pulled
from the studio's lineup ahead of its
planned April 3rd 2020 release the
Michael Showalter film has been placed
on an indefinite hold with no new
release date announced just yet
fans of animated Disney classics and
their live-action remakes were surely
disappointed when the studio announced
that their highly anticipated
live-action reboot of Mulan but also
faced delays due to the coronavirus
crisis before the film's planned release
on March 27th Disney broke the news that
Milan would simply have to wait it is to
say
come in sit down her Niki Caro the
film's director the decision was made
out of respect to the global pandemic
and she took to Instagram to explain the
film's unfortunate delay writing in part
we are so excited to share this film of
the world but given the current
ever-shifting circumstances we are all
experiencing unfortunately we have to
postpone the worldwide release of Milan
for now our hearts are with everyone the
world over who is affected by this virus
and we hope that Milan's fighting spirit
will continue to inspire those who are
working so hard to keep us all safe
currently there's no new release date
set just yet from the lon
sometimes when a film faces delay after
delay after delay it seems like it might
never see the light of day unfortunately
that seems to be the case for the x-men
spin-off the new mutants after facing
multiple delays due to a number of
factors including Fox's acquisition by
Disney and rumors of reshoots that
apparently didn't even end up happening
the new mutants has been delayed yet
again thanks to the ongoing threat of
chrono virus this news comes after
questions over whether or not Disney
would even release the film which was
one of the holdovers from Fox's
theatrical schedule but it ended up with
an April 3rd release date anymore only
to be pulled yet again with no new
release date as of the making of this
video
smaller films are likely to take an even
bigger hit when it comes to delayed
releases antlers are daring indie horror
film starring Keri Russell and Jesse
Plemons is just one example with a
planned April 17th released by
Searchlight Pictures antlers which is
directed by Crazy Heart Helmer Scott
Cooper and produced by horror auteur
Guillermo del Toro has been delayed by
parent company Disney like some of
Disney's other delays including a much
pricier Mulan in the New Mutants antlers
also has no planned release dates as of
the making of this video
the coronavirus related delays and
cancellations are coming out of
Hollywood at a fast and furious pace
indeed for variety as of the making of
this video you can also add CBS reality
TV staple survivor and Amazing Race to
the list both shows that temporarily
shut down production on their current
seasons season 2 production of Apple's
the morning show starring Reese
Witherspoon and Jennifer Aniston is also
going on a two-week hiatus effective
immediately
long-running hospital drama Grey's
Anatomy is also getting delayed but the
diagnosis isn't too dire the current
season is basically in the
with 21 of a plan 25 episodes filmed out
of an abundance of caution however the
showrunners have halted production for
at least two weeks in response to the
virus as for films production on the baz
lurman directed untitled eldest project
has been halted along with a highly
anticipated Mission Impossible 7 with
Tom Cruise and the comedy official
competition
starring Penelope Cruz and Antonio
Banderas and sorry kids the release of
Sony's Peter Rabbit 2 has been pushed
back from late March early April to
August 2020
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and TV shows are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]